this whole coronavirus shut down shut us
all down everybody
we were depressed he had anxiety you
could feel the tension in the air I
wanted to see if this worldwide global
fear had any type of effect on the
spiritual world how much does the
supernatural feed off the fears caused
by the pandemic and unrest Zack
quarantined for ten days inside his
haunted museum to find out that wasn't
the only thing that happened while Zack
filmed his four-part miniseries Ghost
Adventures quarantined for the Travel
Channel he actually picked up on a
spirit who had a connection with me we
got a voice in that voice was your name
what we got a the vault man come on
Kevin listen to me I just got chills I
just got chills well you should because
that voice said Kevin
the spirits said your name the haunted
Museum in Vegas will open back up
tomorrow but after this quarantine
investigation it won't be the same Brown
and ghost
you know once Patrick Swayze realized
that she could could sense him he never
left her alone I feel like that will
only activate the spirits on a level
that wasn't there before the family has
already said if that ghost is talking to
me then I'm out the house by the way you
can catch me on Episode three of Ghost
Adventures quarantine June 25th
[Music]